nouveau rebondissement aujourd'hui dans
la bien sombre affaire du meurtre du
petit grégory et qui assassine et le
petit grégory le 16 octobre 1984
grégory villemin âgé de 4 ans a été
retrouvé inanimé dans la vologne
il avait les poignets liés et une
cordelette autour de coûts il aurait été
la victime du corbeau qui harcelait sa
famille qui n'a jamais été retrouvé mais
il se pourrait bien que cela change
aujourd'hui des scientifiques auraient
réussi à mettre un nom sur l'auteur des
fameux courrier anonyme grâce à une
toute nouvelle technologie l'enquêté
relancée nouveau rebondissement
alors après 36 ans d'enquêté deux
batailles juridiques pensez vous que
nous sommes enfin proche de la vérité ce
soir mais fo stefan et le colonel esma
très proche de la terre sont avec nous
pour y répondre
l' affaire grégory kenji toi qui est
très jeune et scud dont tu avais entendu
parler de l'affairé grégory
l' affaire grégory non je n'ai pas
entendu alors c'est une affaire
incroyable voilà l'affairé grégory
passionne tout le monde depuis 36 ans en
36 ans d' enquêtes et de rebondissements
c'est parfois compliqué d'y voir clair
la sphère grégory c'est qu'on vous a
fait une petite chronologie pour mieux
comprendre 16 octobre 84
le petit grégory villemin 4 ans
découvert mort 5 novembre le cousin de
jean marie villemin bernard laroche est
inculpé d'assassinats et écrouée fin
juillet la mère de grégory christine
villemin est inculpé pour le meurtre et
écroué
elle est libéré une dizaine de jours
plus tard en décembre 2008 2008 qui la
chambre de l'instruction de la cour
d'appel de dijon ordonne la réouverture
de l'anc est qu'au théâtre jacqueline et
marcel jacob grand-oncle est grand temps
de grégory sont mis en examen pour
enlèvement et séquestration et le 16 mai
la chambre de l'instruction de dijon
annuler les mises en examen des époux
jacob et de muriel bollée la faute à un
vice de un vice de procédure cette
affaire n'a jamais été résolu c'est vrai
que c'est une affaire complètement
incroyable c'est un des plus grands
mystères
ça fait t'on maintenant messieurs vous
dites est on avec nous maître rémi
stefan vous êtes l'un des avocats de
marie ange laroche donc la femme du
suspect principal bernard laroche et il
ya des nouveaux éléments qui sont
arrivés dernièrement et apparemment il y
avait un corbeau donc écrivait des
lettres voilà un mystérieux corbeau
c'était en 84 kg et je me suis vengé
j'ai pris l'enfant est a priori avec les
nouvelles technologies pourquoi on en
parle c'est que l'étau se resserre car
des éléments nouveaux ont relancé la
faire à nouveau magistrat procédé à
plusieurs auditions de témoins ces
dernières semaines une nouvelle
expertise
pourrait conclure la sphère a également
été ajoutée au dossier c'est une
expertise en stylo mais tri corps enfin
désigné l'identité du fameux corbeau le
corbeau qui on le rappelle a envoyé de
nombreuses lettres alors mettre remy
stefan ces nouveaux éléments est ce que
vous y croyez
écoutez prudence mais prudence ça fait
trente six ans qu'on nous annonce la
journée décisive dans ce drame
ouais ça fait trente six ans qu'on nous
annonce la preuve décisive et à chaque
fois à chaque fois ça a fait pschitt
à chaque fois ces annonces ont été
l'occasion de mettre en cause des
innocents qu'aucune preuve n'a câbles et
de gâcher des vies donc aujourd'hui mais
la danse l'a apparemment tout le monde
dit que grâce à cette nouvelle
technologie
on pourrait quand même avoir l'identité
du corbeau donc a priori de celui qui
aurait assassiné au petit grégory alors
on parle de ce que les médias mais
appelle la stilo maîtrise je crois mes
stylos être exact on n'est pas sur une
science on n'est pas sur une technique
banque est éprouvée
c'est pas de la recherche de l'adn c'est
pas de la recherche d'empreintes c'est
pas de l'analyse génétique des choses
qu'on sait faire et qui sont
effectivement des preuves tangibles la
silo maîtrise et pas des experts
judiciaires qui sont cons été désigné
c'est une société qu'à l'habitude de
travailler dans le plagiat est ce que
est ce que on le lit est ce que vous
avez déjà les conclusions de cette
annonce
non non non je vous le dit les yeux dans
les yeux vraiment maintenant vraiment
vraiment vous êtes vraiment d'accord
alors on a eu tienne c'est cela qui est
avec nous également par skype ancien
capitaine de gendarmerie vous le
connaissez non je ne le connais pas
alors il était le premier à enquêter sur
le meurtre du petit grégory capitaine à
l'époque il a mené avec ses collègues
les premières investigations sur ce
drame hors du commun
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous capitaine
merci merci monsieur c'est cela pour
vous c'est quoi la sphère grégory déjà
la chair et lloris et c'est pas une
recherche deux affaires c'est d'abord
l'histoire d'un enfant quatre ans qui
est sacrifié à la jalousie à la haine
qu'on voit son père et quand tu
lâchement le saison
1995 c'est ensuite l'histoire d'un
incroyable fiasco judiciaire
posée par une conjuration par quelques
personnes qui vont peser sur une
instruction d'un fragile vacillante à
epinal pour modifier le cours d'une
instruction normal d'une enquête normale
et a mené cette catastrophe qui sont
issus dit cette catastrophe s'est
traduite par la mise en cause d'une
personne totalement innocente été
blanchi après la mère de clips de
grégory et christine villemin s'est
traduit au passage à l'assassinât du duc
de la personne centrale dans cette
affaire bernard laroche ou mahdavi le
1985 était le suspect de viol qui a
voulu se venger
exactement alors là chapeau donc c'est
ça la leyre l'affairé russes sont deux
affaires est là aujourd'hui on
s'intéresse surtout à la première quant
à la deuxième c'est à dire l'histoire du
ch est au judiciaire
je pense que l'excellent documentaire
qui est passé sur netflix donne à chacun
une bonne idée de ce qu'on fait les uns
les autres
j'espère qu'un jour certains rendront 10
rendront des comptes et des
responsabilités à définir vous pensez
qu'on pourra avoir l'identité du corbeau
avec la stilo maîtrise ou pas du tout on
pourra voir un élément mais ont su
beaucoup emballé vous savez sur cette
affaire là on en fait tout un pataquès
aujourd'hui alors que la connaissance
est ce c'est ce que déclarait ce
qu'affirme eux les avocats des parents
villemin qui continue de simplifier
grandement dans cette dans ce dossier eh
bien rien n'ait été apportée
il n'y a rien dans ce dossier à dijon
les parents villemin représentés par
leur avocat allan leur avocat était à
dijon aujourd'hui pour présenter des
nouvelles demandes de travaux et
recherches en adn notamment et il n'a
pas du tout est question de seltz
kilométrique alors je te demande qui a
intérêt à lancer cette affaire-là
et je m'interroge quand je vois tous ces
avocats qui montent au créneau pour
d'emblée joué les gens indignés est
comment dire de défendre des gens qui ne
sont même pas mise en cause
vous pensez qu'on cherche encore à
cacher des choses dans cette affaire
bien sûr on essaie de faire croire que
cette affaire est
tellement mystérieuse que la justice
s'est totalement planté qu'il n'y a rien
dedans dans le dossier alors que d'aussi
mais pas ville c'est pas une affaire
aussi mystérieuse que ça et je rappelle
que simon justice c'est effectivement
bien plantés en 1986-87 à dijon au cours
de l'instruction des quinze mois
d'instruction du juge lambert et bien il
ya eu derrière du grand magistrat et
président de chambre d'accusation a des
petits juges qui commencé leur carrière
de magistrat chevronné qui va travailler
pendant cinq ans sur cette affaire qui
ont tous repris et leur travail si
synthétiser s'est concrétisée par un
arrêt 7 juillet 1993 qui est la pièce
maîtresse de ce dossier et que j'ai dit
deux choses sont très claires qui dit
premièrement le christine dumas est
innocente à 100% je trouve
particulièrement odieux consumant
certains avocats c'est d'insinuer que
finalement la justice est peut-être
passé à côté qu'il ya des choses dans le
dossier d'edf elle ne fait pas clair
c'est absolument odieux parce que
christine villemin où le seuil est à
100% innocent ça c était clairement
établie et aucune personne n'a jamais
été autant il non sans une authentique
elle dans une affaire je serai plus un
show de weck est important à retenir
c'est que bien que l'intéressé soit mort
et bien si magistrats n'ont pas hésité à
écrire qu'il existe à l'encontre de
bernard laroche et charges très
sérieuses d'avoir enlevé l'enfant
exactement alors qu'ils étaient keitel
qui était suspect principal et qui a été
assassiné lui celui qui était assassiné
hélas en en avril 1920 en mars 1985 par
le père de grégory à gori a lui-même et
qui croyais plus en la justice s'il
voyait faire à epinal rim estime etienne
etienne n'est ce pas vous j'ai
l'impression que votre conviction ce
serait que le principal suspect donc
bernard laroche principal suspect serait
donc ne serai plus là et que la faire
elle est maintenant insoluble parce qu'à
votre avis pour c'est que le principal
suspect est peut-être celui qui a commis
le meurtre du petit grégory a minima les
magistrats de divo et les enquêteurs sur
le travail qu'on a fait arrive aux mêmes
conclusions que nous avions
ou de 2 300 enquête c'est à dire qu'il
est qu'il est bien le personnage central
et communaux là il peut évidemment pas
se défendre
donc on ne peut pas l'accuser mais
malgré cela ils 'agit sera encore une
fois combien dit avec des preuves à
l'appui la bia sur le témoignage de
muriel ça des soeurs mais a énormément
de témoignages autour il ya eu également
des expertises en fait ya énormément de
choses qui ont permis à ces magistrats
de le dire malgré la gravité encore une
fois de cette situation qu'il existe à
son encontre des charges très sérieuses
d'abord le b grégory la justice en ce
que se dit à lui qui a relevé gregori
elle redit en 2017
en étant en examen à la fois lisse et le
coup jacob et muriel six mises en examen
ont été annulées pour des questions de
procédure mais sur le fond de la faire
c'est bien assez bien fait que les
magistrats de dijon 10 encore
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui gêne les magies
les avocats de la partie adverse qui
aujourd'hui sont montés au créneau pour
essayer de ne laisser pas de prévenir de
quelque chose qui pourrait se cacher
merci etienne sesmat d'avoir été avec
nous rémy rémy stefan vous avez entendu
vous êtes donc l'avocat un des avocats
de marie ange laroche la femme du
suspect principal bernard laroche pour
beaucoup de personnes le suspect
principal malheureusement n'est plus
alors écoutez les investigations ont été
menées sérieusement par les enquêteurs
cet expert en écriture ont été désignés
dans ce dossier
cet expert auprès de la cour de
cassation qui ont tous dit et qui sont
tous venus confirmer à la cour d'assises
de dijon lors du procès de jean marie
villemin que le corbeau n'était pas
bernard laroche sept experts sont
unanimes et disent que ce n'est pas lui
des expertises vocales ont été faites et
ses expertises vocale sur les
enregistrements de la voix du corbeau
disent ce n'est pas bernard laroche
aujourd'hui moi je suis l'avocat de
marie-ange laroche
son époux est décédé il est plus là pour
se défendre et on entend des enquêteurs
en retraite qui viennent se permettre
alors qu'il n'y a pas l'ombre d'une
preuve contre bernard laroche de venir
mettre en cause sa mémoire de venir
faire son procès dans votre émission
je dis attention attention il y a eu un
fiasco judiciaire
ce fiasco judiciaire il a commencé en
1984 lorsque les enquêteurs étaient plus
devant les caméras que à conduire lors
d'investigations
on continue aujourd'hui et on continue
ce fiasco est ce que vous pensez qu'on
va trouver un jour le l'assassin du
petit grégory ou bien pour 6,6 et moi je
l'espère et marie ange laroche elle
l'espère de tout coeur qu'on trouve la
statue nantes qui rit glory mais pour le
trouver il faut s'appuyer sur des
preuves
c'est la règle dans notre droit on peut
pas venir comme ça à porter des
accusations
quand on n'a pas de preuve et bernard
laroche on a la preuve qu'il est
innocent puisque plusieurs experts ont
été désignés ce n'est pas lui le corbeau
ce n'est pas lui qui a tué ses deux
enfants on attend deux cas les
conclusions de la stilo mettrie puisque
vous le savez que ça rebondit
aujourd'hui